so the starting pitcher alec mills we
know his repertoire is fast sinker four
seamer changers change up slider
curveball known for his location he
lives off of inducing weak contact so
the defense has to be ready because the
ball is going to be in play but mills is
a master at working both sides of the
plate changing speeds and keeping
hitters off balance
first pitch swinging alcantara can't
pick it up and so tucker's aboard to
start here's ben gamel the former brewer
left-handed batter the pitch to gamble
strike three called set him up with the
soft stuff
struck him out with a fastball inside
corner that's out number one and the 2-2
to the cleanup hitter moran here comes
swing and a miss got him on a change-up
two strikeouts in the opening inning for
alec mills the pirates
walk away empty-handed numbers for
stephen brought rare rough start last
time out raised that era up to 457. he
allowed seven earned runs eight hits in
just three innings throughout the levers
almost see him
looks like he's getting it just fair you
heard the sound of the pole there
as omocio cruises in with a big turn
starts it off putting himself into
scoring position first and third one out
here is matt duffy
here comes the squeeze
out
good play to get him
as hermosillo nabbed at the plate yeah
that's a real good play there by perez i
mean
he had to have just gotten them
hermacillo trying to go wide with the
slide but perez cat-like quick here is
ian happ with runners at first and
second and two outs
hit off the end of the bat to center and
reynolds has the final out so a leadoff
double
then a hit but nothing across that's
kind of like that here's the o2
strike three called newman caught
looking two down alec mills looking
sharp so far bounce to short big hop
and sergio just able to throw him out
close play but mills a strikeout and two
outs on the ground we're midway in the
second nothing nothing at wrigley two
men on one away mills probably to lay
down a bunt wouldn't you think
that one funding towards third good punt
brawl up with it and they throw out
mills well done alec mills
second and third two outs and michael
irmacello with a chance to put the cubs
on the board romacillo rips one into
left that's a base hit one in
on his way to the plate alcatra he will
score
and hermosillo into second michael
knocks in two and the cubs lead by that
many here in the bottom of the second so
two nothing and now it's schwendel
on the ground and it gets past tucker
out into left center base hits windell
and it is three nothing rbi number 25
for frank schwendell
stephen brault
it's this inside the third base bag
stephen bralt
has a single and now headed to second
and he'll have a stand-up double it's
his first hit in six at bats this season
one of the best hitting pitchers in all
of baseball stephen broll tucker retired
on one pitch and it brings up ben gamel
and a swing and a miss mills gets him
and alec mills been on point
so far today he's used the ground ball
he's used the strikeout so the cubs with
two men on nobody out and here's austin
romond
on the ground that's through the right
side base hit
duffy around third on his way to the
plate he'll score and austin roma in the
rbi single four-nothing cubs alfazo
rivas walked in the second he's at the
plate now lefty hitter
and he's jammed as his balls bounced to
second newman to tucker tucker to first
double play and are they going to face
alcantara or walk him they will walk him
intentionally with alec mills on deck
and still won't at least through this at
bat bralt strikes him out comes at a run
and they lead four to nothing through
three for stephen brault facing ermacio
here to lead off the bottom of the
fourth inning
this one in the year left field well
struck alfred back on its way gone
look out holy cow
did that make it out of this
i think it did yeah
oh my goodness what a day double double
dinger now for michael hermacio down
five nothing to alec mills in the cubs
anthony alford to lead off and then hoy
park
and a drive to left field anthony
offered a no doubter clear the deck with
a cannonball coming first pitch swinging
alford cracks his third home run it is
5-1
469 feet that went out and got a street
taco
469
foot blast now hoy park puts a charge
into one and this ball is way out of
here clearing the deck with another
cannonball hoy park out of the park at
wrigley his second over the right field
wall pirates go back to back it's 5-2
the 3-1
evans rips one on the ground oh nice
backhanded stop by wisdom who throws to
first dugout by schwendell one away
here in the top half of the fifth inning
excellent defense both corners for the
cubs
swinging to miss mills gets him so mills
bounces back after giving up the back to
back home runs here in the fifth tap
over to third base brings up alfonso
rivas pitch
bouncing ball to first bobble throw to
the plate by colin moran and the out
recorded there colin moran a little
bobble
the throw
was ahead
of the runner here's michael perez he
certainly has the power to tie it with
one swing
out to second duffy one relay high and
sailing into the pirates dugout moran is
in to score
andy green gonna go out there and say
that
that kevin newman
and his slide wasn't legal yeah there's
nothing wrong with that side he's coming
in the foot hits the bag it might slide
over but the hands on the bag so he's
in contact with the bag andy green has
been ejected by tom hallion and he
probably was asking them to look at it
the cubs are out of challenges it's up
to the crew chief whether to review it
or not and tom hallian says no way
anthony alford is at the plate michael
perez who hit that ground ball is at
second base
oh
he hit one as last time
out to center and alford has done it
again
his second home run in as many innings
and the bucks right back in this one
have a day anthony offered one down here
schwindel who's got a couple of hits
drilled in the air out towards left
center offer it back
and frank schwendell has given the cubs
the lead
six five yes sir they had a streak of
three consecutive games with a home run
snapped yesterday and started another
one here this afternoon vermocio three
out of four and they bring in mears
to try to get this around the horn they
go he's safe on the road he changed the
call cory blazer
that's great you'd never see that
i have changed my mind
never mind
him credit
alford has been dangerous here today as
he's homer twice once in the fifth and
one to the six looks like he's gonna
come off the il went too far struck him
out
pirates down to their last chance
swinging a miss struck him out
wick strikes out the side of the cubs
hang on to win it six five the final
frank schwendell with a winning home run
as he delivers
in the sixth